pickles and dickles hippie we got a new
tour alert baby oh yeah the stay trashy
2023 tour is upon us uh-huh come hang
with us gang it's a great way to
introduce new people to the show Bring
the Whole Squad and come see us it's
going to be fun yeah gang it'll be a
party obviously uh this weekend there's
still some tickets left to our third
show at the Gramercy theater in New York
City scoop them up if they're still
available but then we're gearing up and
we're going out baby running and gunning
starting in March we're going to be in
Baltimore Virginia Beach Richmond
Virginia Oklahoma City Dallas Texas
Houston Texas Austin Texas and in April
we're going to be in New Haven
Connecticut Burlington Vermont May we're
hitting Tampa Dania Beach Florida
Raleigh North Carolina then June
Cleveland and Columbus more cities come
and get those tickies now baby yeah
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin and Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast this is are you garbage oh yeah
it's a little shall we sit down with
your favorite comedians and we find that
if they're going to be classy or if
they're just a big old piece of trash
I'm your host Dave Foley coming at you
on a beautiful day we're down here at
antodi's basement she's upstairs
screaming go Birds baby going to the
Super Bowl everybody's excited down here
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he is the CEO of Ru garbage
he is an international businessman he's
the kind of guy that can pull your car
to make it look like an accident give it
up for KJ Kevin James Ryan hey what's up
everybody thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate you subscribe
on iTunes full video available on
YouTube as you know those numbers are
cooking then obviously the greatest gosh
darn website of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage check it
out you get bonus episodes of hard
feelings the whole nine yards we got a
bunch of [__] on here check it out yeah
paying for my dermatology appointment
tomorrow to get this nose fixed how
about a nice quick shout out to our
producer X Jordan Air the magic man
makes us all look good works the ones
Works to twos crosses the t's dots the
eyes plus he's got that big old ding
dong give it up for T-Bone mcgruffins
Toby McMullen everybody
that was a great
he's sitting there staring at me gang
the reason along here doesn't have a mic
is we have two of our old good pals here
in the studio with us they're the stars
of oops the podcast [__] love them to
death one of them recently got a high
five from Jason Tatum and the other one
recently almost got his balls
electrocuted by the Taliban give it up
for Julio gallarani and Francis Ellis
everybody let's go
the better look at us
they are the better looking else man
hilarious what are you wearing Francis
what's that shirt LL Bean really yeah we
were just talking about the bean man I'm
from Freeport Maine so I grew up less
than a mile from the store just walking
around wearing Duck Boots the whole time
you know I didn't buy the boots uh but
we had everything else was being I mean
I would buy a new backpack every couple
of years for school from L.L bean you
have a very LL Bean stature you look
good yeah it was it's one of those
things I didn't know I didn't think it
was cool because we lived there it was
it really wasn't no it was it was when I
was a kid in the 80s it was very cool I
agree dude I did not think it was cool
maybe in the 80s and then like for
people like when I hit the 90s you were
like that was like what your door like
the dorky dad Eddie Bauer started to
take over dad stuff yeah but now uh
they've I guess moved a little bit more
towards kind of being somewhat
acceptable and I start I don't wear I
wear them unironically now yeah with
their clothing uh because it's like all
I want to look like is that new is that
brand new got it at Chris Christmas time
have you washed it no so is that
something that you would wash or you
would dry clean only guys yeah I wash it
because you shrink me as a dry clean
only no dry cleaning doesn't he try to
read the tag bro I play it by the book
baby
yeah dry cleaning is expensive it's
super expensive it is for laundry what
are you guys doing you drop off you're
obviously both New York you live in New
York do you drop off you do it in the
building what do you you probably got it
in there he's got it
I got my I have a laundry on the floor
oh that's which that might as well be in
the apartment that's all right so I
would argue that it might as well be in
the basement
it sucks like you have to because you
know how I don't know doing laundry
requires mustering up energy to do it
the most and when I finally have that
[__] Saka Santa's gift over my
shoulder heading over to the laundry
machine and if there's somebody already
doing it I might not do it for four more
days yeah how many how many uh washer
and dryers are on your floor there's
only one of each but there's only three
there's only three units on the floor
okay and each floor has their own washer
dryer would you ever get other people
this is would you ever get other people
going to another floor to do their
laundry no it's always always your floor
but some of the people on the floor will
just leave their [__] in there for a bit
Yeah but since it's not it's like not
that populated it doesn't end up being a
problem but it sucks in unit would be
significantly better will you do the
trash move of taking somebody's wet
laundry out of the washer and put it in
the dryer I won't do it I know you would
I would not for sure I give you like
three or four or five minutes tops yeah
then it's getting it's it's getting
pulled I think I did it in college once
because we used to have you know it was
like communal sure and there'd be people
who just leave it for forever yeah and
you wouldn't have any so I would take it
out and put it on top and then and and
then put my stuff in and you got a
machine in the in the house right yeah
nice dude the guy in my floor left his
stuff in the dryer and my stuff was in
the washer and I went back three or four
times he did not take it out I decided
I'm gonna fold it for him what folded
put it on top of the machine he comes in
while I'm doing it bro he just thinks
you're a creep hey buddy get off my
underwear sniffing his boxers dude I'm
holding this [__] Bloomers dude and
he goes and he looks at me I'm like oh
yeah I figure we're both guys I didn't
know what else to say there's two and
then I was like I'm never going through
that again what did he say he was like
dare you assume my gender yeah it's kind
of quiet to begin with so it was going
to be awkward just seeing him so like
like he probably wrote the landlord dude
that's the creepiest thing I've ever
heard in my life my girlfriend I told
her the story she ran in bed and put a
pillow over her face yeah that's very
you can't do that to a girl
would you like was the move to be like
passive aggressive like [__] you or you
just felt bad I don't want to leave his
fresh clean clothes to get wrinkled I
might do why why am I touching your [__]
and here's the answer I wasn't being
passive aggressive I just was like my
[__] was sitting in the washer rotting
and I was like all right enough's enough
gotta make a move I tried to be cool
about it I think we're cool I don't know
I'm not trying to have a Hatfield McCoy
situation yeah I'm just trying to chill
dude you know I mean I don't need any
trouble are you currently in any beefs
with a neighbor you're you're a prideful
man you've we argue with he's a [__]
trouble
I'm a beef man and did you knock off
that block in the lane [__] are you
still doing that no I haven't done it a
while that went viral yeah do you know
what I did do though you're gonna get
shot I know but he looks like a guy if I
gotta I'd be willing to if you are
willing to fight and get out and saw him
I'd be like all right uh it's like he's
the guy you don't want to be in the car
size-wise you're you're a nice guy but
I'm just saying the people though that
are getting out of the car to fight me
will have weapons yeah that's true
that's what I'm saying about weapons
can't be doing that [__] out in Brooklyn
but you know what I did get as a weapon
against all of this for me to keep doing
it is I got one of those stickers that
says baby on board
for that
they'll see that
it doesn't even say baby on board it
says princess on board oh my God
he just mean you yeah princess get out
of the car I figured that would appeal
more to the Latinos
on my way to a quinceanera in the back
is written on the back of the car that's
all right what's the uh what's the
vacation planned you boys got anything
coming up you like the hobnob Jump
Around the World well his vacations are
I mean you do make but you do like you
were just literally in Where Were You
Iraq Afghanistan you that was recent
well it was in September so recent dude
if you've ever been to Afghanistan
that classifies as recently yeah dude
that's Miami not a vacation for sure you
were filming it sort of is no but I mean
it It ultimately is it's like a trip
girlfriend always says there's a
difference between a trip and a vacation
I agree with that yes not relaxing at
all obviously uh but was obviously fun
it's a war-torn country yeah that's true
go to Puerto Vallarta like a normal
person it's still a little uh you know
prickly however there is technically no
actual War occurring so theoretically it
is probably it's safer to drive around
there because your [__] fingernails
pulled out yeah I know well not by the
Taliban though because they're you know
you're they're a visitor now and they
they are happy that they're visitors so
they treat you really well they're not
scope what do you mean you're an
American you're you're an able-bodied
board eligible Americans so they're not
looking at you like you're working for
the company they make sure they're
camouflaged dude they make sure he's
over there getting drunk with people
with Falcons what are you talking
imagine imagine showing up to an Army
Recruiting office and being like I'm a
I'm eligible for war and you said that
like it was the patriot dude out there
no so they they kind of like make sure
to cross off that possibility when they
first encounter you which is not fun
you're greeted with suspicion and you're
kind of always worried about how that
might go but once they find out that
you're a visitor they're like hey you
know you're a guest in our country let
us know if you need anything but they
also will probably force you to hang out
for a while really blows and sometimes
that will turn into having to leave your
plans and go far away with them yeah run
give me an example and be held against
your will so like literally I've talked
about you just through that I've talked
about this on our pod it's worth it
briefly baby
check it out oops the podcast the boys
you know we're trying to get to your
level one of these days you know uh but
anyway so usually what happens is they
look at your passport they're so excited
that you're an American that you're
visiting and then they're like yeah they
got another one you're in a [__] cage
that's step one what happened to
Brittany Greiner what are you doing
that's a different situation go to Miami
you don't like doing coke what's wrong
with you different situation however
whatever so they they make us get out of
the car step that's like step two you
get out of the car they take pictures of
you uh they don't let you do it with
your phone you're like bro come on air
drop me that yeah
that's a flex on the gram yeah who's
hanging out with terrorists then they're
like you guys should come become Muslims
let's go and and usually you can be like
nah dude sorry like we gotta go do
something they're like okay like what do
you got to do and you're like
stuff
who's communicating this we have a guy
with us like a guide so they're
translating for us the Taliban guys
don't really speak English so every week
we met one or two that did but 95 no
English that we met and then they
dropped out of their liberal arts
certifications
[Laughter]
yeah my cousin goes to NYU ah no kidding
look at that so at the very least they
are like polite and hospitable to
foreign Travelers including women they
don't treat like women foreigners the
way they treat their own women you know
it's its own problem obviously
um this is in no way a Taliban like
about me vouching for the Taliban sure
uh
I have to make that clear you know I
mean T-Bone keep an eye on this one they
might have turned him step three dude
they will make you he starts making
weird finger signs take them out exactly
step three they will make you drive to
meet the leadership
of the local area they'll be like exotic
Scientology they'll be like you got to
meet the guy you got to meet the
commander you got to meet Tony he's
awesome and we'll be like no no no but
in this one particular scenario they're
like no you you have to and our guide
was like we gotta go and I was like [__]
so now we're driving like 45 minutes
with one of their guys in the car we get
to the compound and these aren't like
you're not on the turnpike these are
like rough looking roads right depends
no they're this one in particular was
paved but a lot of the times there are
some bad roads like the most dangerous
thing I did I drove through what is
considered to be the shittiest tunnel on
the planet uh it's not six miles long no
ventilation potholes giant trucks like
people die from carbon monoxide
poisoning in there so that was scary
that was scarier than this story but
however all right we get to the Taliban
headquarters the commander basically
just forces us to chill there for like a
while couple hours of drinking tea we
don't know what's going on no booze
right there's no booze in the whole
country unless there's like some sort of
weird smuggling if you ask somebody for
a drink they'd look at you look you were
[__] nuts okay even like non-time are
they feeding me at this little Soiree so
they're like sorry we didn't know you
were coming but when on the drive back
you're coming back over and we'll make
you dinner and we're like [__] like uh
the guide showing in my videos and my
stand-up he's looking at it being like
pretending he knows what he's looking at
me yeah oh yes had no [__] idea
that's crazy then that I realized why
it's taken so long one of the guys who
had patted us down drive it comes in the
room with all our luggage throws it on
the ground he's like search let's search
you and I'm like I thought we're friends
he's like we are so that's why you're
going to search yourself and show us all
your [__] I was like okay dude so I'm
like showing them underwear socks I'm
like this is an iPad had a bunch of
money in it but they don't know about an
iPad cover so they weren't like open the
case they just like crackers but had
money scattered for this kind of
occasion they end up finding a huge
envelope of cash you know not to [__]
yeah but like is it Afghani cash no us
hundreds new new issue hundreds only
that's the only thing that you can
exchange there really so they find like
what are we talking like five grand five
grand you had five grand I had more than
that but what are you doing what are you
talking about dude you need it you need
it like first I have to pay the guides I
have to do this to that then you need
like emergency funds you know patreon
we're going to Afghanistan
I'll set you up I'll set you up yeah and
you guys will fit right in dude once you
put the clothes on everybody looks like
they're Afghanistan
I'm not joking
there's a little girl who looks like
she's related to him in the video I
don't know like anyway so then they find
they end up finding money
they count it on video to prove that
they're not taking any and then they ask
me once the camera's off for a bribe
like what do they like have so the
problem is I'm I'm thinking it's going
to be half or all of it and they just
ask me for 100 bucks
absolutely there you go you sure that's
all you want yeah I'm like I'm out of
here yeah that was it wrap up some of
that naan bread too
that was the worst and then they were
all embarrassed and [__] that that they
had taken our money so they wouldn't
look at us after it was weird as [__]
dude uh and that was like the shittiest
thing you didn't you didn't talk you
didn't tell the part about how when you
got to the house they had tons of oh
dude like yeah like we're talking the
talent remember remember he laid their
guns down remember the gun that Val
kilimer has in heat like that like
Gatling gun sort of like thing they have
those in the room that I'm in like two
hands required to mount on the back of a
pickup truck they all drive Toyota
4Runners sure and they will just [__]
mow you down and dude apparently they
are all just marksmen like they were
telling us these stories about guys that
were just up on mountain tops like
picking people off without like a thing
like a scope or anything like these guys
are like career soldiers it's all they
know so there's probably
a hundred guns in this room and like all
semi-automatic weapons like very [__]
intimidating and the guy's like oh he
sit down here's some tea you know uh
super panicking it all during this a
little bit but I got my poker face on
I'm I'm like showing a pair of twos
you know I call huh yeah and then there
of course they're asking you like how
you feel about the Taliban and you just
gotta [__] line be like I love the
Taliban
yikes but all good I would say now that
all is said that's said and done like we
end up starting this like little school
over there which is a really nice thing
what you did yeah so now we're figuring
out how to send money that's how to
become a Taliban but
so dude this is the problem no no so
it's like not a Taliban Affiliated
School we've gotten local permits from
them though I love how he started at
school and I'm like I'm cheating on it
of course it's a good cause that's the
squad as the football team yeah yeah I
didn't mean to hijack this episode like
commercial vessel got to the school
they're all on monkey bars but my
biggest fear now is so we have this like
Law class helping us uh like figure out
how to send money wait who started this
school uh me and like these local guys
from so like the low I met with all the
local teachers in this Village and like
our guide was from the village so he
like arranged it and we had this like
Round Table discussion for like an
entire day about the plan it was like
crazy it was like a game of
thrones-esque gathering of the local
tribes wow um but now so the law class
just responded to an email from us being
like hey guys just please stop sending
money to Afghanistan yeah dude until we
further review what you're allowed to do
we just want to make sure you're not in
violation of any crimes because you
could face serious criminal penalties
like Jesus Christ yeah dude the FBI is
going to show up at your [__] house I
I think we'll be fine dude I mean we use
[__] Western Union like
yeah that's how criminals launder their
money dude I know but I don't think
that's for drug dealers and dirtbags
it's all good we sent unmarked bills but
I'm not sending it to anybody doing
anything bad and there are like limits
that Western Union has in place
hopefully that are in in line with these
International laws right and you're
trusted Western Union have you ever seen
the people that use that it's the only
way to do it checks cashed Aki dude yeah
apparently apparently the uniform at
this school is all these kids wear these
vests that have big pockets
and we just had to dress the entire
class
dude get out get out of there yeah would
you do something like that would you go
over there
um I know you're an adventurous guy I've
done I also know you're a goddamn
American he went to China I've done a
lot of Adventure probably for real see
now he's ratting people out look at this
one this is crazy bastard over here I
mean between the two of you we got a
[__] incel and a [__] gummy bear
holy [__]
I uh I'm at a point in my life where no
I I I don't like a Hawaii guy get to
feed up some White Sands I feel like if
you showed up if you showed up in
Afghanistan they would assume you're a
[__] CIA uh maybe and and and I think
that like for me an adventure now would
be like go to Japan or yeah maybe South
America yeah not he he you you have a
true
fearlessness Death Wish and I he's
presented it in a lot of ways where I'm
convinced it's not it's not Reckless I
pitch it to him every time either he
passes fairly fairly formally yeah we
had dinner uh for your engagement yeah
and I pitched the Iraq idea I was able
to sort of sell you guys on it which was
good Afghanistan was a more difficult
hurdle Afghanistan there were there were
we you had friends I don't think you
knew about who were contacting me and
being like we need to talk him out of
this this is Ricky one of them yeah
that's crazy there were people there
were people that we were like we don't
want you to go yeah yeah and I
appreciate that concern to be honest you
know good friends I I appreciate them
looking out for me but I believe in my
mission dude which is what I think that
like you know these risks that we think
are so risky are not as risky as we
[__] think yeah
[Laughter]
he does have a line
yeah I do he has a you you have places
you won't won't go I tried no active War
zones
uh that's pretty much it he was looking
like a [__] green Beast dude that in
Jacksonville won't go near it never go
back on a cruise again
the way he said to me that uh Mogadishu
in in Somalia is you know you have to
wonderful this time of year yeah
you have to hire an army you have to
hire like 20 dudes with guns to protect
you to go anywhere but it's like 1200
bucks a day did you go there no you
won't I was scouting it I don't think I
would go there this is all for videos
for videos but I'd like to just go also
the video to be honest allows me to
justify doing it I would love to do it
anyway the video I enjoy doing those as
well but I'd like to just go also like
if I wasn't making a video it wouldn't
stop me from going to do a reaction
video eat like the old 96er in some
place find a kangaroo get views a
different way
these things aren't even generating that
many views that's the shittiest part
about it
I'm really trying to build up the
channel but it's not going too well
[Laughter]
do one of these places are going to keep
you and you're going to become their
Simple Jack it's my fear
I would really hate that dude
and you come back and it's supposed to
be this triumphant moment but too much
life has gone by yeah and you just never
settle back in fully yeah like Tom Hanks
and Cast Away jeez yeah I miss your life
in captivity Stockholm syndrome hate to
say it dude the show is sponsored by
better help yes it is okay let's talk
about that better helping love that
better help baby I'm a client myself yes
you are crazy as they come this one you
shut up okay yeah gang we all got things
going on God knows I do and the better
way to get that off your chest is to
talk to somebody about it and they have
Specialists that you might not have in
your hometown and you can do it from the
comfort of your own home oh yeah baby uh
better help is a therapy option that is
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely done online you fill out a
brief questionnaire you get matched with
a licensed therapist and switch
therapist at any time at no additional
charge it's easy peasy baby uh like I
said I use it it's fantastic the the
communication is easy they have live
chats there they have live sessions you
can just do messages whatever you want
it's easy peasy I highly recommend talk
therapy it is a game changer if you're
struggling with something out there and
baby like the big man said we all are if
you wanna if you want to live a more
empowered life therapy can get you there
visit betterhelp.com garbage today to
get 10 off your first month that's
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash garbage do we
okay let's talk about true classics
classics I've been seeing them ads all
over Instagram everywhere they're great
I've waited out of them a little bit
they only go up to 3x but it's still a
good product yes because my fat ass
can't fit into it anymore I'm wearing
one right now they're fantastic is that
what that is this is an old one too this
one's this one's got about 300 washes on
it too and they hold up they're great if
you see me wearing a tea I'm a true
Classics man they got a nice Cut in his
shoulders they make you feel good
they're a little wider around the belly
area because I like a nice beverage you
know what I mean that's what you need um
they're fantastic uh it's a new year new
you like I said I love them they're
fantastic I order I try to keep them
fresh you got to cycling new ones and
then get like a three pack with the with
the promo code garbage you save you know
a couple few shekels sure and then you
just constantly working them in you
throw one out you get a new one in you
know what I mean do that whole 3x take
off too yeah they're for the big boys
yeah you know bigger boys bulky guys
husky kids that used to be husky now a
true classic I wear them around the
house I just can't wear them out sure
you got one on each leg you get 25 off
at trueclassics.com garbage get free
shipping included on purchases over 100
bucks that's 25 off at trueclassic.com
garbage Santa won't be the only one
slaying thanks to True Classics now back
to the show back to the show that's all
right I mean that's a jump dude yeah
that's why I forgot I did know that and
I forgot about it did you see any of our
gear over there do you see any
Blackhawks or any of that [__] there's a
couple like they keep sort of like tanks
that they've destroyed on the side of
the road for to like as a thing of Might
uh there's a couple Humvees like active
Humvees but for the most part you don't
see that much the car choice Toyota
Corolla from an older one too uh and any
nice car like a like a Land Cruiser or a
forerunner Taliban guy is driving that
damn yikes yeah dude crazy [__] wild
you should do a spin-off are you the
Taliban
only on patreon.com
awesome dude so all right that's crazy
holy [__] all right let's get into some
[__] cues here
[Laughter]
where where his trip would fit on your
guys scale of garbage it's just it's
just insane it's just it's like off it's
not even guard it's just like where'd
you sleep did you guys go back to the
city like tell my mom I just thought it
was a guy who was in Afghanistan guest
houses they're basically hotels but they
call them guest houses and who said to
who initially set this up for you tour
guide It's not like Perillo Tours no but
yeah I'm in this Facebook
I'm in this Facebook group that you need
to apply to get into and it like
basically asks you like how many places
have you been like you get interviewed
basically and then there's access to all
these kind of tour guides in these
quotes I mean that is kind of trashy of
your book and you're your vacations on
Facebook groups yeah you want to hear
the most recent group that I had to
interview for to join on Facebook was it
was it was the [__] Greenwich
Connecticut
furniture sale where you have to live in
Greenwich Connecticut and you get these
moms who are like we bought an entire
living room of Restoration Hardware
couches only to have me realize that's
not the vibe I was going for so I gotta
make space because now we're going with
this other stuff would anyone like to
buy this 16 000 sectional for 400 bucks
just come take it just come take it yeah
start doing that we had to interview to
get into that group are you I'm waiting
how did you how did you Juke the system
somebody told me you you changed your
you change your all of your Facebook
information to say that you live in
Greenwich and that's it and then you
have to like kind of prove that you live
in Greenwich and that you're not just a
Furniture Hunter quick Photoshop yeah
and this is also because you want this
kind of furniture
uh we're you know we're looking for some
like coffee tables and some like she go
to West Elmer CB2 or something yeah
that's that's dude I'm telling you you
can get way cheaper than what those
stores sell in some of these Facebook
Marketplace groups but if you go to like
the really Elite neighborhoods and can
kind of fudge your way in they don't
really care about the cash
that's that's actually a good Loop
that's very small that's real that's top
tier dirt bag [__] yeah these two are
[__] bonkos Jesus Christ
about
[Laughter]
tables in Connecticut where are you
going next nowhere like I don't have
anything like that planned at the moment
I'm like in the weeds editing and all
this [__] uh for now it's just like road
comedy stuff and a bunch of [__]
weddings okay what about you you got
anything on the books for the summer you
get out or you go you're a skier you go
you're going out west or anything yeah
yeah I'm going to Telluride Colorado to
ski there you go my favorite place to go
so awesome uh and you ski your snowboard
ski just ski really yeah snowboarding
trashy yeah really yeah he's wearing
that little bean you think he's yeah
what do you got k2s snowboards
there there's I think there are still
three mountains in the United States
that are skiing only it's Ulta they're
the only ones he goes to Deer Valley
both in Utah Alta and Deer Valley and
then there's one I think it's Mad River
Glen in like New Hampshire or something
like that and uh you don't see any
snowboarding only mountains no no
because they would just be a disgrace I
mean it'd be
a drug future
a bunch of guys wearing blue jeans
Monster Energy Drink going around yeah
and can you handle the the rough stuff
can you do like the double black
diamonds or whatever it's called I grew
up skiing in Maine it was like you know
you'd have 20 below wind chill just pure
ice all the Snows Brook blowing off the
mountain I need to be out there being
like this is fun let's do another lap
yeah hitting the Moguls so we're out
there [__] living I gotta do
something get on that Facebook find out
what the hell is doing that infection on
your nose all right before you try
extreme sports it hurts so bad
um CPAP scars CPAP scars man it's
[__] jammed up I was sick last week
and I slept for like 14 hours and I
guess it was like rubbing up against my
my nose and the [__] just got
infected that on the south end of an
eight ball I did but put everything on
it I treated it for everything yeah he
came up hey man I swear to God it's my
CPAP machine I put it I put a breather
on and I put neosporum on it I put his
own on it nothing worked so I'm going
going to the Durham tomorrow get it
looked at go see Dr tricolio straight
man
[Laughter]
he's making meatballs while he's talking
to me
um all right let's hop into some [__]
cabbage questions here guys as you know
when you sign up for the patreon we were
answer your garbage question on the air
it's just the best way to do it speaking
of doctors uh this is from Jose ten
dollar homie never had one red is it
garbage if your oral surgeon is
connected to a Jimmy John's
which it shouldn't because it's but if
it is you do qualify your doctor by what
it's next to life sure right I'd say not
necessarily dude it might just be one of
those commercial strips Jimmy John's is
a good tenant uh it's true they are they
are an anchor store probably it's a big
retail change over money probably paid a
few months up front not as trashy as it
might seem uh either one of you guys
have braces I did you did where was your
doctor at was it in a house no really it
was in one of those Orthodontics
sort of professional centers I don't
know what you'd call it sure you had to
drive in everything looked exactly the
same they're like real estate offices
and
a dermatologist probably I don't know
Professional Building big in the Philly
burbs for it to be connected to a house
I never had braces but I went once and
it was in a house yeah it's real real
weird vibe I remember my our guy would
have his dog running around at like six
I'm like this can't be good
you got that thing and I all stuck over
the dander falling in there you guys
both had them I didn't have them I had
the uh the appliance that goes on the
top where it like cranks it's like a jaw
gear no no it's a pilot expander pallet
expander yeah I remember I could feel my
head I could feel my bone moving that's
not fun when they did it yeah I had him
for six years because I was so bad with
them oh damn I never [__] wore my
rubber bands because I I have a overbite
and so they took the rubber the hooks
and rubber bands out and they put in
these things called Jasper jumpers which
were like sounds like a firecracker
they would push my jaw out but they were
on they were on like this little track
in my mouth they were it was like thick
cable it was [__] brutal man if I
open my mouth too quick it would like
catch it was I wrestled with that [__]
for [__] four years in high school it
was brutal
you know my teeth are still on the
junkyard you know the Jimmy John's thing
the
people I know have started as their
business buying franchises of these fast
food chains yeah and like you get
emailed all the time you start with like
one Burger King or something like that
and then they'll add like two Subways or
whatever that gets a sense of the
business it's not easy it's all and it
also takes a lot of money it takes a lot
of money a million dollars and and
getting the right to buy one of the
franchises is hard like they don't just
give you they're not like hey go ahead
Build a Burger King or whatever
um it's not some Facebook group you say
that yeah it's a little more vigorous
this guy this guy said you know that the
heart they were like what's the hardest
thing for you and he said that um it's
it's Staffing because like a lot of the
time you know like a lot of days you'll
get a call from like the manager of the
Burger King being like we have no money
eighty percent of the staff didn't come
we've nobody here and he has to like
call people and be like where are you
and they'll be like Oh I'm sorry I'm in
prison again yeah or like I'm going to
rehab or like I have you know all kinds
of hours
um and so just like it's it's impossible
to staff and he's had to go and like
work the register yeah my brother my
brother and cousin ran Dunkin Donuts
like his like my uncle bought them and
my brother and my cousin managed them
they were like yeah we just ended up
having to work at Dunkin Donuts like
yeah you just have to open and close
because no one wanted to do it like you
just spent like nine hours a day at
[__] Dunkin I have no idea they
thought they were gonna be like you know
executive Fat Cats yeah we're just
employees at Dunkin Donuts yeah what are
you doing investment wise I'm sure you
dabble in some things you know I have
been away I've been made aware that I'm
not smart when it comes to investing
right so you play the market as they say
you know I just get caught up in [__]
like I that's my kind of investing dude
I just put some money in crypto voice
I got nothing anymore I dumped it all
you know for pretty significant loss
whoops
at least I got something you know and
that loss is a write-off yeah it is damn
right do you have an IRA uh yeah I do
okay yeah kids are right I haven't I but
it's not it's not substantial it's not
like I couldn't I couldn't retire on it
yet okay um
exactly well enough the remainded
furniture for a little while I I don't
know I mean I uh no I I guess I I just
have learned that you know having cash
is never like the worst thing in the
world okay having something and you're
having money in your checking account is
never bad like you know Frank Cardone
says you know that guy yeah he's telling
everybody don't buy a house is it a guy
with the gray hair yeah that guy's gonna
crash he's always cursing on like uh
like uh talk shows and stuff like that
he's the kind of guy who's like never
buy a house just get your money
buy something yeah yeah so I don't know
I mean I don't know I I I try to just to
just not be stupid but I also desire
things a lot you know I get swept up in
things that other people want fads yeah
like what drop one dude I could I could
trace I've said this to G before I could
trace my entire life answer this for you
I could trace my entire life from one
fad that I was hooked on to the next
okay starting with like beanie babies
and then Pokemon cards and then going
into like cards oh dude real lady killer
anything skateboarding
skateboarding and then on to like
collecting DVDs for some reason okay you
know uh sneakers yeah sneakers pretty
good then I then you start the older I
remember I remember being younger and
hold on you had Beanie Babies of course
how old were you around eight oh all
right seven okay not not an adult
collector saying my whole life I could
it was just one thing for something that
you were a part of for a year like I
have to have I had the magazines with
like the oh like the dark blue peanut
yeah
[Laughter]
did you play with uh action figures when
you were a kid not really when I was
like five maybe I had I had some Star
Wars action figures I did and I'll tell
you what mine were this is a very
garbage thing mine were all secondhand
like I had I had action figures that
were cool in the 80s they were I had
like He-Man and like we bought them from
tag sales stuff you could watch correct
that was like currently real you bought
them from tax sales tax sales like well
there's another word for it I'm sure
garage sales okay so like on somebody on
their [__] front lawn is selling
their old [__] I would get all those
that's where you would get your toys so
I'd have like Skeletor and like [__]
from the 80s it was like no longer even
in syndication really wow yeah
I don't want to like throw my parents
under the bus I did have some current
ones like they got me some like
Ghostbusters you know I mean but a lot
of the time we grab something I don't
even think that was Kurt when you were a
kid
you're playing you're playing with the
six million dollars man I had the Dan
Aykroyd
oh boy never got the Bill Murray but uh
brother oh it's hard to find that's good
all right all right let's see here is a
garbage to play the same game movie or
show on multiple TVs in the house for
surround sound
it never syncs up I gotta respect it man
it really fills out the room I'm sure I
Gotta Give a gift to you it never syncs
up
that's like an idiot savant yeah yeah
like just buy speakers dude you have to
you need more TVs yeah yeah I guess you
have to have every team that makes I
guess it makes sense to me though yeah
right no because it doesn't sync up
because the TV is always like a second
behind the other one yeah and also not
for nothing why would you have two TVs
in the same room no different rooms I
guess okay but then then you're then
you're getting an echo oh he's clearly
not the sharpest tool in the shed all
right
he's not a Beanie Baby collector give
him a break will you but theoretically
this guy's watching it on cable in which
case it would sync up that's what I'm
saying I guess yeah
white man can't jump son I mean [__]
throw down in every room at my parents
house if you put something on downstairs
and something on upstairs it's the same
cable thing the one downstairs is a
little bit behind interesting yeah Toby
or the The Tech Guy is shaking his head
yeah that makes sense okay yeah there
you go did you get caught up in the
surround sound [__] did you have
speakers and all that stuff off uh well
do you have a speaker behind the couch
now you do now I do you have that now
yeah I didn't I didn't before do you
have a sound system which is we got
Sonos
what's Sonos Sonos is awesome
sodas is great I'm glad you brought that
up Foley
yeah uh no they're they're it's like uh
it's really well yeah but they they make
you know you can wire your whole house
with it so like we have a Bluetooth one
in this in the uh kitchen okay or
whatever for music and then you have we
have a sound bar and some of the some of
the behind speakers yeah oh the sound
bar they'll be got them for us for
Christmas and I gave mine away and I
think he threw his out Jesus Christ why
it sucked that's fine oh my God damn
Savage
the one thing I worry about with the
sound bar living in New York is that the
bass will make your life difficult with
your neighbors and [__] yeah however
they do not make like flat screen TVs
with loud enough speakers so like I find
myself turning my ship to a hundred all
the time which is annoying no I agree I
agree once you get a decent surround
system you're never going to realize
that you're missing out yeah and let me
tell you something this is the crazy
part when you have the the subwoofer
going if you ever watch NBA game time or
NBA the one with Charles Barkley Kenny
and whatnot when Shaq speaks
scares the dogs off the couch from the
subwoofer his voice and his voice alone
that's crazy
it's just the whole thing rumbles that's
nuts that's absurd
that's crazy shout out to Shaq yeah
Legend he's an investor yeah he buys all
those uh fast food franchises yeah huge
investor in fact well I think at that
point when you can buy like a bunch of
them yeah and you're like you're not
gonna see Shack drawing fries you know
what I mean you know what he says it's
really smart too just to get him just to
get some free [__] he did this when I
was waiting tables at Bareburger came in
with like a squad full of people like 20
people comes in sits down brings over
the manager he's like I'm thinking about
you know investing in buying a
Bareburger everything's [__] free wow
all the all the burgers I don't know if
he's doing that for free food he knows
what's that guy makes more money than as
he's ordering then we make it he knows
what he's doing
so he's gonna go to the guy the waiter
and be like hey I'm thinking about
buying one of these I'm telling you
that's exactly what happened I was there
you've never fibbed off we gotta see a
shack let's pull up Shaq's portfolio see
if he owns any bareburgers he doesn't he
doesn't yeah exactly he walked away I'm
never in a bear he's been refreshing it
ever
you and Jack work together bad
financials bad financials not overhead
sweet potato fries are all right though
uh place is great yeah he made all he
made a [__] ton of money in the Google
IPO really Shaq yeah he was playing he
was in a Lobby he tells a story he was
like I think it was Google he was in a
Lobby uh playing with this kid like a
like a real nice hotel lobby and this
kid came up and they were just playing
together or whatever like he was waiting
he had like 15 minutes to kill and then
this that hit the kid's dad came over
was like hey man thanks a lot for doing
that I was whatever whatever
and he's like you know if you and he
gave him the tip he was like a big exec
he's like hey we're gonna go you know
we're going public on this date or
whatever if you can get it so they like
he got in yeah you'd be getting tips
from your from your squad all the time
uh I don't I don't know about you're
supposed to be on the inside people
aren't hitting me up they're hitting up
like Venture Capital firms okay you know
what I mean the people that I know are
like they don't they don't want 10 grand
for me
that's not what they mean
[Laughter]
I got a great opportunity for you what
do you mean he won't take a Mark Maguire
rookie card did you tell him about the
beanie babies
[Laughter]
they need and it's funny I earlier in my
life there was one that I I kind of
missed on where I did it was that it was
like a 10 grand thing what was the
company it's called forto they make
these like espresso shots that you can
buy at 7-Eleven in little plastic cups
and you could have got in for 10 G's
yeah 10 G's and like I didn't I was like
this is these I tried them didn't really
like them I was like I don't I don't
know and now they're in like every seven
really yeah I want something somebody
hit me up with something I mean you
assume the problem with that is like
it's it's never as crazy as you think
because they'll do a round of uh
fundraising and you get in for your 10
grand and you get whatever like 0.01 of
the company and then they do another
round at a new valuation as they're
growing and the only way to maintain
your steak is to now reinvest to at the
new valuation to maintain your original
position if not you get diluted
you still make good money but it's never
like oh I bought one percent of the
company and then 10 years later the
company's worth a billion dollars I get
one percent it's not like that that's
what happened to the kid at Facebook
right the one that got screwed Andrew
Garfield's character uh so he had 30 of
Facebook as as basically a handshake
deal because he was CFO and had invested
in his own money and then they had they
had given him paperwork as a new
restructuring one of the guys of he
thought they were his lawyers well he
thought they were friends he thought
Mark Zuckerberg was his friend and
without reading the fine print they
diluted his shares but did not dilute
the shares of any other early investors
damn Savage but then they settled and he
made over a billion on the settlement oh
there you go hey Dad Zuckerberg see me
in your Facebook group short
um this one's just funny this is Thomas
ever go through a reggae phase
reggae uh I did for sure when you find
out about Bob Marley you're like I got
as a kid yeah it's almost like it's
almost like hard to put Bob Marley in
some sort of like reggae
he's because I I think he's an enduring
amazing musician yeah that was in the
genre if you went beyond Bob Marley and
got into like he's got in the weeds of
it Uncle reggae you might have been
bunny Ferguson or whoever it was yeah
that was that was class he was just
lumped in with classic rock to me Bob
Marley Bob Marley yeah when I started
getting into classic rock when I was
probably in seventh or eighth grade was
Steve Miller Band first then like
Zeppelin Pink Floyd The Doors uh and
then Bob Marley was thrown in there Bob
Marley's Greatest Hits but yeah beyond
that get the [__] out of here you listen
to Wacky [__] I used to I had a little
bit of a reggae face not as hard as some
of my peers but I can I could throw some
names at you who's you Banton
Barrington Levy
in general not my favorite genre I do
listen to some crazy [__] you do I see
you posting [__] and I'm like where like
yeah I like smoking doobies I guess I
don't know I like a lot of like like
Latin trap music too Latin trap music
Julio is the guy who he's you're a man
of very very many different tastes when
you when you see that some someone's
musician has been killed and you don't
know who they are you'll go to his
Instagram and he's got like an rip
that's how that's how present he is with
music
you two are very funny dynamic because
like you know you're obviously all right
Peter Winston thurington Clemens or
something like that yeah totally you
come from like uh you know the ivy
league background and everything like
you're one person and you're different
but you can operate in the same circles
he can 100 that's my friend group you
you can walk in both worlds pretty
seamlessly thank you and I think like
you know he could put him at a party in
the Hamptons yeah like you got enough
dirt under your fingernails but you're
also very very cool and you're like hey
do you hear this music and these you
know francis's friends are like what the
[__] this guy's all right for what it's
worth I can operate in that in the lower
world I just choose not to
yeah I don't like it the lower World
welcome to Thanksgiving I can get the
dirt under my fingernails and be like
whoa you guys drinking some fun stuff
today was that Jungle Juice in the
cooler oh man show me a glass but I
don't go there you sure eyes I don't
like because you wouldn't be able to go
back to your other circles I just I
don't have enough to talk about with
those people I they don't they're not
reading I don't
it's we run out of Road pretty quickly
just picture you and another guy just
staring at each other you wear shirts me
too man yeah you ever make a bomb
I don't know are you reading something
right now you're reading a book right
now I am yeah what are you reading uh
hold on a second is it fiction or
non-fiction fiction fiction yeah it
always fiction no you do it not
perfectly two two fictions in one
non-fiction this might sort of run out
at the same time no no like I'll do two
back to back I'll read a novel read
another novel and then I'll read it
cleanse's palette history yeah and what
are you reading before you go to bed
yeah and then in the morning I like
reading in the morning to start my day
I'll get I get up early I wake up really
early what time I'm like 6 30. get up at
6 30 have a coffee yeah do some exercise
I assume no what kind of coffee are we
talking uh what are you making it in all
right we got our own coffee from
Brooklyn Roasting Company
yeah
it's pretty good coffee company
oops Bland it's awesome uh we have a
Taliban blend yeah
Afghani beans
that's what you're over there broker
yeah that's right it's getting in the H
game
deals
uh yeah so I have a coffee and then I
sit in a chair and and just sort of
watch the sunrise and Pat the dogs and
and read my book for like an hour it's
great really easy way and then when are
you working out
at four to five p.m 5 p.m you wait till
the afternoon yeah are you having
breakfast oh yeah what are you having uh
I have the overnight oats still oh that
we've talked about yeah last time I was
on the show kid's a machine what are you
doing I mean in the morning yeah I just
kind of wake up
take an edible call up Ricky no I don't
do anything I don't I'm not like a
routine person uh and I'm not saying
that proudly like I just am not so it
has this pros and cons but I don't need
to like relax and ease into the day some
days I like to do that but I don't have
like a thing like him I just wake up and
shower or whatever and go do my [__] sit
on my computer for the record
um this routine sort of became more
regular when we got this puppy because
the puppy wakes up super I went through
myself yeah and they changes it changes
everything her bladders just sucks so
like you know unless if you don't get up
with her she's gonna [__] and piss on
the floor she's gonna ruin the day and
then you're like motivated all right so
I have to get up and then you're up
you're up at 5 45 6. yeah yeah and
you're like well I'm not going back to
bed so I might as well just do something
just regardless of what time you go to
sleep or do you go to sleep on a
regimented schedule every night well we
know that the dog's gonna do that so
we're pretty more it just makes us more
tired earlier yeah and we end up going
to bed at like 10 o'clock do you fall
asleep easily yeah I know you wake up
easily and can't go back to sleep but
you fall asleep easily yeah I fall
asleep no problem and do you regulate
your stand-up spots like do you not take
spots after a certain time I have I have
been I've tried I've asked the booker
hey you know I can't I don't I don't
prefer chips but like until you have a
kid it's kind of of a [__] thing to be
like sure
can you not give me the late spots but
for the most part you're in bed at 10
o'clock every night
it's 10 30. damn that's pretty good yeah
lights are off but I need a little bit
of that are you guys like that night
owls depends yeah it depends on the
spots but definitely if I'm home no
spots 11 I'll probably shut it down or
at least I'll be like on the couch like
lights out just kind of [__] chilling
whatever I'm all over the dog's already
walked uh but then you know if I'm booze
or whatever you know
tends to be different I don't have
regulated spots sometimes I get ones at
like 1 30 2 o'clock and like all that
might be the only spot that I have and
I'll leave at like midnight to go and do
it and then come home and then I come
home and then I eat something I'd love a
schedule I'll tell you this as I get
older getting into bed early man at 9
30. taking a nice hot shower it's really
nice that's actually on the weekend
because in the weekend you feel like you
you don't have to but if you do it on
the weekend and you're like up you're in
bed early and you're up early you just
have someone feel like yeah yeah and you
use your weekend better you don't have
that like hungover anxiety that prevents
planning oh you know I mean you just
can't do anything except consume you
know what I mean no I've never heard it
put any other way yeah or just do
anything here's another thing that's all
I can do is consume yeah I've been off
the booze for about a week like the last
time I drank uh well we together that
was that Saturday that I that that
Brooklyn Comedy Club I had a couple of
drinks and then I think I went out to
dinner the night before but after that I
haven't [__] drank in a while man it
really makes a [__] big difference
sorry oh yeah yeah no once you drink
your choice oh what's my drink of choice
uh I'm tequila and sodas I like tequila
and sodas I like a martini but I just
[__]
stop no bueno sorry where he's at no uh
uh I know I took I took a bunch of days
off too maybe like I drank I think once
or twice in about 21 days uh and then I
went out this weekend and like and
there's just nothing better than like
[__] saddling up to a bar
associating with the boy it's like oh my
God this is what I missed that's what
it's all about I did the same thing I
tried to do like a I tried to do a dry
January it quickly became a like damp
January negotiating it yeah you're just
like making concessions for yourself and
the it it ended three or four days early
I mean definitively ended you know where
what are you drinking negronis uh I do
love a Negroni I like I like beer I like
good beer I've really gotten into good
beer I posted a picture of the main IP
at lunch IPL the main beer company oh my
God I love that that's also Freeport
Maine so that's also that's like within
main dudes love Maine yeah yeah Bane is
a great place I am very happy that I
grew up there Kenny bunkport yeah not
far probably like 45 minutes before the
bushes live yeah I've driven by their
compound it's out on like an island but
it's not an island it's like it it's
just its own sort of disconnected piece
of land but I mean they've got an
armored you know driveway with a house
with like a guy and almost like a toll
booth guy but you know he's strapped of
course he's not collecting easy yeah
there's a great story about how there's
a great book by the way uh it's called
the president
no one has ever said that in this
podcast
you better make taxes for dummies uh you
better be talking about Hustler I think
you guys would like this uh
it's called the president's club and
it's it's DiCaprio in it if not I'm out
um it's it's basically like uh the sort
of how how a lot of presidents certainly
in the 20th century would even After
exiting office maintain a foothold in
the White House and advise the next
presidents and you find out about how
um like Nixon especially was was so many
presidents after Nixon would call upon
him for foreign policy advice and he
would like come back to the White House
even though he was disgraced
um and and these people allegedly yeah
like even even presidents that had run
against the incumbent and had unseated
them specifically Clinton unseating Bush
senior who you know you you're basically
you're in debates against each other and
you've stolen the guy's job right those
two forged a really strong friendship
which uh there's a great story in the
book about how Clinton would go up to
Maine to the bush compound in
Kennebunkport and they would take the
motorboat from the dock in Kennebunkport
and Bush would be driving it and they'd
be going like you know 80 miles an hour
or 60 miles through hurtling through
waves just the two of them did down to
Portland to get like a lobster roll or
something but like tossing around and
having a great time trying to get their
dick sucked
ultimate shot and beer with the boys
hell yeah yeah that's awesome that's a
hang dude yeah
um all right let's see here I'd love to
get you know francis's adapter guy
this is from Cooper uh is it garbage to
run out of an undershirt and wear a
regular t-shirt under a button up for a
suit
wait what's the difference like there's
a difference between an undershirt and
like this t-shirt I'm wearing is an
outward t-shirt so he means like okay
yeah like also what how do you how do
both of you feel about the T-shirt under
the dress under the dress it's a tough
look
it's a very tough look it's not because
you see it got a great move
the only way you could justify it I
guess it's such a it's such a thing
where you wear it to I think right if
it's really hot out to prevent this way
to try to prevent the sweat it makes you
hot but it makes you hot so it's a it's
a you're it's a very tight rope damn if
you do damned if you don't I don't
understand what the what t-shirt it's
the same thing what's an undershirt like
one of those Hanes they come in a pack
of three super light dude if you wore
that you could see the purple under your
shirt yeah they're always white
typically over 500 episodes into this
you're 46 year olds that were explaining
colors to you at this point no I mean I
would wear if I would if I could fit
into a Hanes t-shirt I would wear an
aims t-shirt no not outward though
they're like see-through kinds they're
really sheer and you have to understand
what an under you don't know what an
undershirt is they're thinner into an
outward like that's a t-shirt you would
wear out to a podcast recordings but I
would wear this under a button-down
shirt
dude
if I really want the job yeah
so what [__] Barney
what's the job
that you're applying for where they're
like
oh I couldn't open notice this is our
guys
who told you you're supposed to wear
gray under a white shirt and then you
can't see it
now I mean I I don't know maybe I would
have thought white under a white shirt
yeah most most of those undershirts are
white or you'll get black so you go no t
I don't wear a t but that's I I'm gonna
sound like a douche here it's usually
because the button-downs I'm wearing are
too tight for me to wear a shirt
underneath
do you know what I mean yeah like most
of them I I'd be I'd be bulky who was
your suit for your for your wedding
would you wear suit supply suit supplies
they're great they were great they're
not custom made no no they're off the
rag it's not expensive you got it
tailored though right yeah you gotta get
it like him I don't know yeah brought in
a little in the back tighten her up I
let mine out uh
what I'll do sometimes because it's
tough it depends on the the the white of
the shirt because I got chest hair that
you then see through the shirt if it's a
light shirt yeah which is a problem yes
right get your waxaroo it's just too
much so this is a dirt bag move but it
works and no one you can't tell the
difference if you do want to go
undershirt cut the sleeves off and on a
shirt yeah swear to God let them know
your [__] party you don't see it if
you take your when you take your jacket
off you don't see the sleeve
and you can't tell because the the seam
stops at the seam for the above shirt
pretty good see what I'm saying like one
of those under armor type yeah yeah make
sure one next tapes but hold on a second
make sure it's a stone cold
[Laughter]
you're wearing a white button down yeah
right and underneath it you've got a
Haynes some t-shirt that you've cut the
sleeves off of because I like the party
can you still see the the neckline from
the t-shirt do you cut that off you also
cut them are you telling me you be you V
it too yeah yeah
you're like a fashion designer
taking liberal choices so then you're
not wearing a tie
no I am wearing
it so but you said if you slice up the
underwear too just oh my God I put a
hole in the back
I cut the toes off my socks too just so
I can feel the ground better kids ready
to play I mean it sounds like you're
spending a lot of time with some
scissors and some shirts and that
trimming your chest here would be a lot
easier
you know how many times I've been in
like a hotel room getting ready for a
wedding like cutting the neck off a
white underskirt
yeah that's great that's great it gives
you that extra layer of protection you
people out there know what I'm talking
about
I won't be the only one I also love the
idea that you get so skilled at this
that for for Christmas also a v-neck
work so you don't have to cut the oh you
could yeah you can buy the v-neck
undershirt so yeah yeah but wouldn't you
see that wouldn't you see that under
though not necessarily we got the
collars there I mean it's not like a
deep I'm not like it's not like coming
down here it's just I would never take
my jacket off if I had a [__]
button-up on
yeah I typically keep mine on the
daytime outdoor wedding is the thing
where you really have to worry you know
what I mean yeah but that's hot I I just
keep the coat on and let it let it soak
up all the sweat I I I just I'm like I'm
gonna be hot I'd rather they not see
agreed agreed but for the other the
other thing is you know you're gonna
have to probably dry clean your suit
anyway and I get a lot more satisfaction
knowing that I've fully soiled it your
money's worth your money's worth yeah
I'm Really Gonna [__] in these pants I
don't know what you guys do back there
but you've got your work cut out for you
were you wearing a suit so stressful
yeah yeah I mean we've saved a bunch on
this it's especially as you're a bigger
if you know you know a big guy or a
husky or guy the second you're never
gonna look as good as the second you put
it on there's a it's a quickly law of
diminishing returns it's like yeah the
fuse is lit you got to get in the car
that's gonna the shirt's gonna pull the
ring as soon as I sit down it's over
back in the car oh I got smoked I had a
linen suit for our rehearsal dinner
thing our bridal dinner and I I pulled
it out of the you know
plastic wrap from the dry cleaner it was
crisp you know steamed it sure some lady
that was working there at the wedding
and uh then we went we went to the
rehearsal dinner with a steamer just on
hand it was like for mostly for like the
ladies you know uh but but we were we go
into uh we go into the shuttle to go
over to the restaurant and I'm just
sitting in the car I get out and someone
snaps his photo which I like posted
because I thought it was really cute and
all the comments were like man you
couldn't run a [__] iron on the back
and I'm like I had one on there 10
minutes ago yeah yeah
yeah we're just getting ready at
wherever the place is yeah if you you
know just take your take it to the
wedding reset or the wedding uh service
and just get dressed in the bathroom oh
like an old school comic uh-huh yeah
right right before you go on yeah hey I
just lit them all right you [__] get
ready
um all right this one's from Tim crawl
big McGraw Monroe or something uh you
ever been the only guy in the room in a
suit
which could be a tough look interesting
because I doubt it's for the reason of
like you're the CEO you're either wildly
overdressed or you just got out of court
I would assume that's also a comedian
thing potentially what like the guys who
only wear suits oh yeah that'll happen
to them yeah I remember Patty Dixon used
to be rocking the series yeah Pat Dixon
used to rock this suit all the time I
wore a suit one time to Gotham's new
Talent bringer which was really oh my
gosh I just didn't know myself heard a
suit to a bringer yeah that was not not
great luckily everyone was like I just
assumed that he had come from work
[Laughter]
dude I went to a sort of like funeral
memorial service for a family member and
made the mistake of asking my brother
for the dress code that's the that's
also that James jump real bad yeah I was
like what's your dress code he's like
like business casual I wear a suit I'm
the only person yeah it sucks that sucks
you feel like a real [__] you got an
interview after this you cannot relax so
like you're just thinking you're like
does anybody else wearing a tie they're
like oh Mr City guy yeah dude yeah I get
older you Mr New Yorker yeah I'm like
yeah trying to upstage the deceased he's
in a football jerseys
what do you think you're better than the
dead I went through uh a brief Blazer
phase in comedy in Philly for about a
couple of months
the first time I ever saw him ever my
uncle he just died and I'd gotten all of
his old suits because I was the only one
that fit him in the family that fit him
talking about old funny suits shout out
to my Uncle Mike
um yeah and I would wear his suit coats
as Blazers with a t-shirt underneath
because I was cool
he was hosting an open mic that we were
above for the first time I ever saw him
we were hosting he's hosting the oven
might get the Raven Lounge
2009 probably 10 yep sounds about right
and he gets up there all right you know
clap it up for your host H Foley he goes
ah you know he's really he had the
Showmanship already like he was playing
up you know what I mean and he asked the
crowd by round of applause should I wear
the Blazer should I do no Blazer no like
for like a three minute set he's he's
negotiating with the ground whether or
not to do a Blazer and they're like no
Blazers like all right I'll take it off
for you like he was about to really let
his hair down I'm doing nothing and then
they were like Blazer
you cut the sleeves off that go back to
the Blazer is the Raven Lounge the one
that's like four stories yeah and it was
like on the third floor yeah yeah so
I've done that I've done that Mike yeah
it was it used to be all right I think
the building's I think it's closed now
the whole uh the whole establishment
Francis is like an honorary Philly guy
in a way yeah you're going down there
for week night shows yeah yeah I like it
I like it I'm going on uh Wednesday this
this Wednesday to do helium and uh I
love going down it's just like such a
close gig it's great and it's a great
comedy City too
real Rough and Tumble crew down there
which I'd like to see uh all right let's
do one more then we gotta get out of
here this is from Luigi F baby anybody
you know where the visor with the hair
already built in
you always see some dad or uncle on a
golf course
this is the funniest guy in the world
that's great do you guys know anybody
that wears a toupee anybody in the
extended family never I've never seen it
no I I wouldn't no no you wouldn't you
and you wouldn't be able to wear it in
my family immediately somebody they
would make red on your head yeah right
away they'd make fun behind your back
and then as the drink started going so
I'm like you gotta [__] take that
thing yeah you just gotta let it go
you're scaring the kids yeah dude I've
never seen one I've seen some pretty bad
comb overs yeah I'm rocking these days
but no are you rocking a comb over
theoretically I don't think so man I had
a history teacher
[Laughter]
you're cutting Corners somewhere
[Music]
I'm making choices okay
gang having a nice round of applause for
the boys from oops the podcast Francis
Ellis Julia gallaradi thank you we love
you guys so much congratulations on
everything what do you guys got coming
up you want the folks out there to know
plug away any shows fire away I'm on
tour uh you can find tickets for that
francisellis.com come to your cities and
uh check out Hoops the podcast
appreciate it 100 yeah uh same not
julio.com DC third to the 5th of March a
bunch of stuff coming after that uh yeah
check out oopsa podcast that's it stay
away from the Warlords for a while right
go down here to Boca with your friends
listen to your friend Ricky enjoy
yourself I hear Ukraine's nice this time
of year gee lean into it and become an
arms dealer yeah at least wait your beat
though just think you have the closest
connections that we would need yes to
get into the heroin business or the or
the small arms start another school in
Syria
because that's real Shifty man he'll be
trading me for Brittany Greiner sooner I
don't think
even with the eye if she met you pay
that right now
gang we love you to death Kippy you got
anything for him uh uh this is coming
out Thursday so the shows at The
Gramercy start this weekend baby there's
only tickets left for the Friday Night
Show get them now if they're not already
sold out we [__] love his three shows
it's amazing we appreciate it Kang we
love you we'll see you next week